- Just let her finish it up, so (beep)
(laughing)
(techno music)
- I am a grandmother.
I have three grandchildren.
- I have never heard of Flip Cup.
- You turn the cup over,
and you have dice in there,
and you then you pull it back?
- Oh no! (laughing)
- I have heard something about like,
chugging in colleges?
- Chug-a-lug, chug-a-lug, yeah,
chug-chug-chug-chug-a-lug.
- I may look very sweet and nice,
but watch out!
- Sorry you gonna lose, but, you know,
that's life.
Somebody has to win.
But, I always win.
- So, this is how Flip Cup is played.
We open our beer,
and we pour about a
quarter of the cup full.
Drink our beer.
Line your cup up, and try and flip it
onto the opposite side.
- How you expect us to do that?
- Once that lands, the
next person in line goes.
Trash-talking is essential.
The more they're thinking
about why they suck,
the worse their flip is gonna be.
- You suck!
- Exactly!
You nailed it, Willow!
If and when you win,
because you're gonna win,
make sure you celebrate for a long time.
(dance music)
♫ Time to get up ♫
(yells)
- Alright, ladies,
we're bringing in a team
of people who have never
played Flip Cup before,
so I need you to crush them.
Alright, I know we can do it.
Grandmas on three, bring it in.
Alright, on three.
One, two, three, Grandmas!
(cheering)
We're ready.
(choral music)
- Newbies, are you ready?
- [Newbies] Yeah!
- Grandmas, are you ready?
- [Grandmas] Yeah!
- Alright, let's do this!
- In your face.
- Go Chris, go!
- You can do it!
- Drink all of it, drink it!
- She already drank (laughing)
- Go Grandmas, come on!
- Go, go, go!
- Oh, come on.
- Come on, Willow!
(bell dinging)
- Sorry, sorry.
- Aw man!
Grandma's got me.
(bell dings)
- Aw, there it is, Grandma!
- Go, go, go, go, go!
(yells)
- Come on.
- Got it, got it.
(bell dinging)
(cheering)
♫ Time to get up ♫
(dance music)
- It was a lot of fun,
and I'm drunk from it,
because I drank about four things of beer.
- It was so much fun!
- It was expected.
I was ready to win.
- I'm bratzed, I'm embriagada.
- We're good, we're good.
- It's good to get older.
You bring all your experience,
and you tap into stuff
that you've done before,
and look at that.
You beat the young ones.
- Well, I wanted to do the cheer,
because I was a
cheerleader in high school,
for the BuzzFeed.
Gimme a B and an E and a D and an F
and the F is for (beep) and an E-E-D.
BuzzFeed, BuzzFeed, you're the best!
I put that bad word in there, though.
(laughing)